the modern Western World believes in
human equality believes in the idea that
all people are equal and worth and value
but the thing is that that idea didn't
really exist anywhere
500 years ago when Europeans first made
it into this hemisphere it was not a
concept that had really been developed
yet so when they came here they didn't
view the Indian tribes as equal to them
any more than the Indians viewed their
enemy tribes as equal to them that that
didn't exist you think the Indian tribes
were talking about equality and the
tribes they were warring against were
equal to them no absolutely not they
didn't believe that